[Music]
here in this video we will address one
important question that arises from the
jurassic world dominion trailer and that
is where did all these dinosaurs come
from
if they were not seen in fallen kingdom
and the island is destroyed then how
come they exist
well stay tuned for a conclusive answer
till the end of it we have also checked
out thoroughly the canon behind jurassic
world not including the game evolution
but all the five movies leading to this
final flick and also the animated series
camp cretaceous so let's get down to
business
first question who created these
dinosaurs in the franchise well the
answer is [ __ ]
it's a product of john hammond and
benjamin lockwood they were dear friends
and business partners who shared a dream
of bringing back dinosaurs from
extinction they pulled in their
resources and created a laboratory in
the basement of lockwood's manor dr
henry wu a geneticist was engaged to a
system with the genetics work and by the
mid-1980s they formed injin a genetics
business whose mission was to continue
the development of dinosaur cloning the
operation was then relocated to site b
on isla sauna later on where the
dinosaurs were reared and released into
the wild in both isla sauna and isla
nubla
next question what are the dinosaurs
that escaped lockwood's mana during
jurassic world fallen kingdom
well to confirm the real topic about
this new dinosaurs that were seen in the
trailer we first have to know which ones
were rescued from isla nubla
and these are the allosaurus the
ankylosaurus apatosaurus baryonyx
brachiosaurus carnotaurus comstognathus
gallimimus nasoceratops patchy
rhinosaurus a group of duckbill
parasaurolophus pteranodon cyanoceratops
stegosaurus sticky moloch triceratops
the t-rex rexy and blue the velociraptor
all these dinosaurs except blue were
locked up and were about to die due to
suffocation of a toxic gas but was
released into north america by maisie
lockwood the clone version of lockwood's
daughter
so what are the new dinosaurs seen in a
trailer of jurassic world dominion
well after stating the different species
that were rescued in the last movie and
escaped from lockwood's manor we now
come to the trailer and there were quite
a few dinos that weren't a part of that
group
and these are the giganotosaurus the day
lofasaurus the atrociraptors the
pyroraptor the quetzalcoatlus and the
terraxinosaurus
these were never a part of the old
movies well except for the dave
lophosaurus and that was only seen in
jurassic park the first movie aside from
that none of the other five have ever
been cloned
well to answer this question of who
created the new dinosaurs and why
we have to know a little bit more about
who owns engine now
what's the deal about maserati global
and the fate of injin in is the new
blarin isla sauna well to answer the
first question the answer is that after
hammond's death the company [ __ ] was
acquired by the multinational
corporation called masrani global who
was run by a friend of his sanjay
masarani sanjay's dream was to build a
bigger and better park and this led to
the creation of jurassic world an
indian's work in cloning new species of
dinosaurs as well as creating various
hybrids like the indo-rex the
interrupter and the scorpius wrecks
proceeded on without much of a speed
bump on the way
but what is the fate of injin in isla
nubla and isla sauna after the events of
fallen kingdom where the volcano pretty
much made the entire place uninhabitable
so even though the majority of the work
was done in these two islands
most of injun's initial research was
performed in palo alto and some time
after masrani bought the company injun's
headquarters was moved to san diego
injen purchased its lasagna as a
location for cloning and to grow the
dinosaurs injen and masarani maintain a
worker village and a breeding station in
that island even after the events of the
third jurassic park movie when masarani
bought the place and started work on it
again for jurassic world and all the
diners from sauna were transported to
the park in nubla so sauna is a dead
zone as of now
so aside from san diego engine's
headquarters that is now heavily
monitored and after the events of fallen
kingdom and cloning of new dinosaurs
would be next to impossible especially
with incidents like the bell at big rock
and lockwood manor's numerous human
casualties aside from this does [ __ ]
have another site well the answer is yes
it does with masrani's global reach
there are various sites where such work
can be done indian's most recent site
martel is located in siberia its present
goal is to collect place to see in age
organic compounds from glacier ice that
is
organic compounds from a time after the
dinosaurs but it could very well be the
site for new dinosaur cloning and
evidence for this is the scene from the
trailer that shows a pyro raptor let
loose from a facility that is located in
a very harsh arctic environment
again aside from martel in siberia i
suppose there could be other separate
places like the one seen in the trailer
where alan grant was taken to via
aircraft this could be the main site for
further dyno experiments and cloning
but if this is it then what's the
objective is it engine's security
division behind it all as we know from
both jurassic world and fallen kingdom
dinosaurs were very valued assets and
each specimen no matter the species
could be
worth millions of dollars and could be
used for many things the raptors were an
asset to indian security division which
has ties to the military and they were
looking for dinos to take the place on
space of black ops and even open warfare
the indiraptor was yet another example
for such a goal in mind this hybrid was
designed to attack on command but was
ultimately too chaotic to control
but wait a second here what if engine
with all the things that happened in the
last two movies is now defunct
especially in this field and is now
under heavy purview from the government
you know with all the deaths and
failures of the park and all and with
lockwood's manor's black auction they
are pretty much tied up
are there others that could follow suit
and pick up the pieces henry wu himself
stated that if they didn't do it then
others will
well there are a couple of rival
companies that are not that far away
from recreating dinos the way [ __ ] did
these are biosin and manta core and it
is quite logical to suspect that if
engine isn't the one behind it all then
one or both of them are
biosyn is a genetics company similar to
injen and matako the company is known
for stealing ideas from other scientists
it is also the only biotech company
which has or which employs more lawyers
and subjects skilled in corporate
espionage than scientists it has been
confirmed that bioscene will appear in
the sixth film
the only staff member confirmed to
appear is lewis dodson
after the jurassic park incident biosim
has tried various attempts at claiming
engines technology for themselves they
even paid 500 000 to daichi bureau to
buy engine which was going bankrupt at
that time but the japanese creditors
wouldn't sell so bison is quite a
suspect in this case
and the other is manticore it is a
bioengineering and genetic oriented
company that was mentioned in jurassic
world camp cretaceous the company is
often seen sending spies to attempt to
acquire engines and mass running
global's research and technology for
their own purposes both genetics
companies rival indian and maserati
global and they engage in corporate
espionage and morally dubious business
practices and they have attempted to
engage the services of individuals
affiliated with the parks to steal
crucial research from them
if either of these two are sus then it
would explain the appearances of the
atrociraptors and malta hunting down
claire and owen brady i mean look from
this perspective
new dinosaurs that were never a part of
the previous movies or books hunting
specific humans in a densely populated
city thousands of kilometers away from
north america
well seems like someone perfected the
goal of weaponizing these extinct
creatures for nefarious purposes
even the pyro raptor that was let loose
in the facility in the arctic region
seems a little bit suspicious and also
even the giganotosaurus requested
cordless and the terezinosaurus all
going for the same individuals looks
like someone wants them dead
so what's the conclusion well we might
have just found out the plot for the
movie as well the old dinosaurs are
definitely part and parcel of engine and
they were the ones from fallen kingdom
the new ones however have a very new
smell to them they might not be injured
on maserati's work but of a rival
company enticed with black ops agencies
trying to perfect the art of weaponizing
dinosaurs species for both warfare and
other purposes this would explain why
the new atrociraptors were in malta why
the pyro raptor was let loose hell even
while the quetzalcoatl is teaming up
with pteranodons to attack the airplane
that owen and claire were in this all
smells the same as the umbrella
cooperation of resident evil and reeks
of dinosaur weapons
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video anyway with that we come to the
end of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam